tesla to launch full self-driving car
uh subscription within four months ilama
says that tesla will launch it
it's full service uh in the next three
to four months the automaker is set to
launch the option for full self-driving
package which cost ten thousand dollars
at the purchase of a new tesla vehicle
here's what you get with the package
navigate on autopilot
auto lane change auto park summon
full self driving computer traffic light
and stop light control
stop sign control tesla also plans for
the package to eventually lead to
full self-driving capability but the
automaker has already missed a few
timelines on that front and even if it
achieved it the release will be
dependent on regulatory approval which
is market specific
yeah okay that package is missing the
driver
just saying
[Laughter]
so what do you think because i know
you're an uber guy yeah a tesla comes
out with something like this would you
buy it
is this true you don't drive a car i
don't know no i don't know
i haven't had a car in 10 years it's
it's it's actually the world is a safer
place yeah
sidewalks of boca raton are safe yes
well my bicycle is pretty rad dude
um did you say two is it really though
you have one of those
you have a real nice bike or you got one
of those like uh beach cruiser i'm not
i'm just taking my time
you know it's good for south beach i'm
not trying to win a marathon here but
back to tesla wow so much fun
danielle imagine if we had some wine
here this i feel like we do a late night
one night um wow like this is happening
like i remember seeing you know test
drive you know have you seen the you
know the cars with the sign on it like
the jetsons
no well that too but you would see
driverless it would
have a sign on it driverless car like
you know just be careful like we're out
here
and it's happening like there's full-on
driverless cars now so like
you for instance you joked about it
earlier imagine
you buy a tesla you're pat you got zoom
calls you're doing
interviews you got you're doing dream
team meetings and you're not even having
to look at the road
this is pretty impressive stuff this is
like where we're at right now in
in life right now in 2021 is that you
just get behind a wheel of a tesla
self-driving car that all you do is sit
put the address it goes to it would you
buy it
i i mean or would you still stick to
uber like would you buy it would you buy
a self-driving car you don't do the
driving it's purely automatic the the
thing with me is why i didn't have a car
was because i lived in downtown miami
and
to get anywhere i was going it's all
within a two minute five dollar uber
yeah and half the time quite frankly i
was going to south beach and
partying and drinking and the last thing
i needed to be doing was having a car
so if you don't and i've said this a
million times if you don't have a car
payment and if you're not paying for
insurance and you're not paying for gas
and maintenance and flat tire and
somebody hits your rear of your mirror
and
you're driving a curve and next thing
you know even nailing it like you can
save a lot of money
and i've saved a lot of money not having
a essentially a ten thousand dollar
expense
for 10 years putting that into the
market who knows what's happened in the
market like
i've gone on on that so for me it's not
about oh i don't want to
actually drive it's the it's the
financial component but
for someone like you who it's
has kids has a family it has to drive
around you're moving you're grooving
and you're doing 10 different things all
at once i don't see a reason why you
would not consider this
i would i think if there's a
self-driving car that takes me anywhere
the challenge is also i like driving
though i
enjoy driving that's great i
let me tell you what happened the other
day the other day i missed having a
stick shift
like i missed driving stick shift cause
like a friend paul oh
i mean you know it's is your stick
shifter no
wha which car is stick shift the
challenger no it's not yeah yeah
is that a is that an option like you
have an option to pick up stick [ __ ]
no it's full manual it's 100 million
percent
oh let me tell you not have the option
to drive it like that does nothing for
me
it's like so you want to do more work
just to get where you're going i need to
like be reversing and neutral
i like driving okay i like speed but i
think for business i would absolutely
buy one
if there's a self-driving car luxury say
you have a nice
escalade luxury self-driving car that's
going to take me
what have i told you that you need a
million times
a driver a personal driver yeah straight
now you have it built in and you don't
got to pay the person why it's not
fully it's not fully fully what's it
missing
it's if it's a fully self-driving
capability
i am all in one of my cars will be a
self-driving uh
car yeah once the technology is proven
i'm all over it
i am but i'm not going to be the guinea
pig okay so you're waiting
yeah you're kind of like uh how no
you're going to be the guinea pig with
the vacuum let me ask
you are you guys not driving yeah you're
okay
so you would be okay to just get into a
machine and it takes you place and
you're not driving
absolutely i'm not a fan no no i mean i
i would want the option still to drive
but yeah
75 percent of the time i don't want to
drive eric youtube
i don't like driving no sam do you like
driving
no more than an hour sam loves minutes
kai what do you think
so i think there's two components
obviously initially if
if all the cars are digital and driving
by themselves
i feel a lot safer if you have people
like sam driving and your car is
peacefully driving
uh self driving then that could be an
issue there
i'm good then yeah i can do that yeah
but then also
there's the second component though
there's the second component and that is
with
with cars and think of how
you would change driving if you don't
have to change you if you don't have to
drive there say you have like a desk in
the back or you can do something
productive and still show up where you
want to go uh then you don't have the
component of travel
time because that could then be
incorporated into doing whatever you're
doing anyways so essentially how we move
around would
completely change in that case because
now a four-hour drive
is you watching a movie for four hours
and you get up
you get out of the car and you're
somewhere else or you've got wi-fi and
you're working
exactly you've got your laptop going in
my opinion your your
um little narrative there about like i
love driving is gonna be
you know a few decades from now the
equivalent of someone saying
oh i just love horseback riding i love
it i got a horse i love it it's my
favorite one
like i think that's where we're going
like there's eventually you're so
there's going to be every car is going
to be dry like it's going to limit
accidents uh
it will mitigate it will mitigate
traffic all that everyone's going to be
on the same page and you can just do
what you want to do
okay that driver who's driving slow in
the fast lane
that won't exist that's every day to
work florida people
i don't understand slower drivers why
are semi's driving in the far
left lane like i don't get it buddy
you're in the wild west here you're in
florida no no by the way
honestly no joke terrible drivers i
don't know what they're doing like here
why are there's
driving in the far left lane there's no
you know what i put out the top
california texas or that uh or
or uh florida atlanta's bad best drivers
atlanta best drivers new york california
best drivers california texas or florida
who are the best drivers
in texas i say california really yeah
hands down florida's the worst hands
down oh we got eight year olds
we got people who just showed up in this
country like i don't know where and they
don't know what's going on you got
tourists you got europeans
they're driving on the other side of the
world prejudice with people that show up
out of another country
i like i liked your time your tan brown
skin you look great
oh i did great on you so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you